uh
how most modern is this 2008 uh i've
been having a lot of dreams lately that
are narrated by morgan freeman
that's just true right delivery what
it's me it's so weird
he's not even in the dream it's just his
voice
i'll just be i had a dream i'm not
making this up i'm running through a
graveyard from a vampire just sprinting
it's foggy and misty just out of nowhere
booming just like surprising to say
peter wasn't sure
but he would get away from the vampire
he wasn't wearing the right shoes
those are just lines from other movies
it doesn't even relate to the show
i don't think i didn't notice your
matthew mcconaughey shawshank redemption
got me to thinking
yeah i don't know
thank you you're not even honey it was
good that's right you got to relax the
bottom jack
great morning sorry no no no it's all
it's all fun
i'll tell you this
i am that guy i have the barbecue i'm 29
but i'm already that guy that's like
embarrassing the people i was like yeah
i like the ti tmi
you can have whatever you need
i'm already a bad person
embarrassing dad
and i can't i'm embracing it now i was i
was at a hotel i was checking in with
some friends all in our 20s and the guy
and the person behind the counter goes
uh okay some of the rooms we have one of
the rooms we have is a non-smoking queen
i go
[Applause]
[ __ ] what
who makes that joke
that a 29 year old guy living in big
apple thing i caught the big apple
i call it the big apple i call it the
pot i can't help this
i'm fun dad
fight i don't do it for your humor
not a persona
i embrace it though on the holidays i
shake kids hands and give them twenties
like fun dad happy holidays
on a fishing trip i'll let a 10 year old
try beer why not
you got to be careful though there's a
thin line between fun dad and creepy
uncle
it's really thin
it's not even a line as much as it's a
blonde mustache
when did they decide that that was the
uniform [ __ ] [ __ ] up people they
were just like you like something really
gross really really gross yeah like you
need a van with real blinds like real
like house blinds in your car that's out
like wooden like you bought them at pier
one and they're like this is nice for
your living room yeah my living room
you be my [ __ ] van
if that's how evil it is stop shaving
here you fair-haired monster
let the world know
if you see if you have a friend that's
not i don't make the rules if he has a
blonde mustache he wants to molest you
he might not even know if i see someone
coming at me with a blonde mustache i'm
like he better have been drinking
viscous lemonade
we're up and running the hell out of
here this is lemonade it's my band
not really but i was talking about
dreams and morgan agreement and i i i'm
not cool
in general but i'm not cruel in my
dreams and isn't that where i'm supposed
to be cool isn't that my fantasy land
where yay whatever i need i'm fine no
it's not even i'm not good with women in
my dreams which doesn't make sense
that's where it's supposed to be good
and like because in reality i'll be like
hey ladies and like in your dreams no
not it not even there it's not happening
i could be somebody else i had a dream
that i was like a spell oiled up like
puerto rican dancer that was beautiful i
was like yeah shimmering in the sun
there were sheets white linen crying in
the breeze there was this lovely woman
that was like yeah let's have sex on the
mesa and i was like see
very limited
and then like right when she got close i
was like i'm just kidding
i'm vaguely heavy
seal the deal i don't know what i'm
doing even there on that landscape
i'll give you another
i just saw a group of young girls
dancing in their underwear and i don't
know what most people in that institute
yeah it's a sex dream the next thing you
know you're having sex not in my dream
in my dream they were dancing like that
like the like the crucible but hotter
you know what i mean i'm just ranting
slowly and in my dream instead of sexing
them that's what i thought i took out my
phone
and started taking pictures of them
in my dream
like these'll be hot later
i can't wait till i'm dreaming that they
leave
that i can then dream that i'm looking
at these and then have a sweet dream
that i'm masturbating
that's the dream
and morgan freeman's like that is really
nasty
seriously man [ __ ] those [ __ ]
i don't know how to end that joke either
no
do you get mad at you do you guys i'm
kidding
i don't know if you like it rough yeah i
wish morgan freedom over here he'd be
like i know how to end that joke
you know when your dick is in the [ __ ]
you know what i'm talking about you're
dipping it real deep into our guts and
you're just pointed straight down it's
not even pleasant to you anymore one
foot up on a kitchen counter
i don't even sound like morgan freeman
anymore
but you know what i mean just pointing
it towards the earth to punish yourself
because you grew up jehovah's witness
so you know
so you're defecating in a woman's mouth
right
you guys ever take two girls one cup
you're just watching it spread eagle and
hitting walks jack nicholson
it's the most unrelatable [ __ ] ever but
then the punchline is like that well
that actually happened
oh god my freckles are in here
they are endearing